in 2020 Faye says she was assaulted by a
stranger on her way home an event that
left her traumatized and feeling the
Metropolitan Police did not take her
seriously I fell
belittled and dismissed over the phone I
didn't
feel that it was taken seriously the
fact that
I wasn't assured that
this might not happen to someone else
that the Met couldn't dispatch somebody
to patrol the area just made me have
really little faith in how much they
value women's safety or Public Safety
the forces review of phase account
deemed the service they provided was
acceptable but said that several points
of learning were identified the report
added I apologize on behalf of the
Metropolitan Police that you felt it
necessary to complain
zarelina was minutes from her front door
when in June last year she was attacked
and killed by a man who was on license
and had just been released from prison
Jordan McSweeney had followed several
women that night but the alarm was never
raised Zara's Aunt blames this on a lack
of trust between the community and the
Met why didn't those women call the
police is it because they don't think
they're going to be taken seriously is
it because they're so scared of what
they know about what
um ex-police officers have done to women
themselves trust that's particularly
hard to find in some communities June
and Shola have been working with
marginalized people and the Metropolitan
Police for decades they praised some of
the officers they've worked with but
this review confirms what they suspected
of The Wider Force as a black male
I've been stopped by the police
so many times I can't even tell you how
many times if we keep waiting on report
after report to get this right how many
more lives are we going to lose or
effect
or have traumatized young people coming
up
a retired DCI from the Met who worked on
the Wayne cousins investigation says
keeping existing officers will be
difficult the majority of people are
hard working that now that retention of
those officers
has got to be part of this as well to
keep the good ones there to change
things for good because they're going to
feel like this is a personal attack on
them
to avoid an instant like this all sides
agree change is needed this review was
commissioned because these women were
failed baroness Casey's findings show
Britain's largest police force is
continuing to fail large parts of
Britain's capitals